[Musique]
oui
vous allez avoir un écoulement nasal
avec ressemble à un coton-tige si je
peux je peux simplifiée qu'il faut donc
utiliser pour les dans la narine
perpendiculaire ce pôle enfoncé de 3 à 4
cm jusqu'à arriver en butée foldingue
donaghy tourné cinq à dix fois un appui
envers leurs narines et ensuite le
tremper dans une solution que vous aurez
préparé préalablement y laisser reposer
la solution pendant une minute
avec la solution placer un compte goutte
la solution ça va déclencher une
chromatographie le liquide famille et là
vous allez voir bande rouge qui va
apparaître contrôler que les tests
fonctionne s'il ya une seule bande bien
vous êtes négatif s'il ya deux bandes
vous êtes positif et il faut s'isoler le
tout la séquence complète dure une
quinzaine de minutes
oui et ce n'est pas rare puisqu'en fait
l'utilité de ces auto test et de
d'élargir les mails plutôt resserré les
mailles du filet et de et d'avoir les
cas positifs résiduelles c'est
véritablement un test qui est là pour
arrêter quelques cas positifs c'est un
geste barrière supplantation petit je
pense que la place de l'auto tests de
façon très simple très clair et on ça a
été dit c'est pour aller dans les lycées
c'est pour aller d'un verre le personnel
enseignant c'est pour aller dans les
quartiers on ne va pas par des
associations et ça et ça c'est utile
oui